on continue avec mon interview portrait
aujourd'hui patrick poivre d'arvor
bonsoir donc vous re publié chez balland
la traversée du miroir nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure avec mes camarades à
commencer par frédéric beigbeder je vais
parler un petit peu de vous vous êtes
présentateur du 20 heures de tf1 est
l'homme le plus regardé de france est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment ce
n'est pas pour disques quand on les
photographies on leur vole leur âme est
ce que c'est vous avez ce sentiment là
est ce que le fait d'être l'homme le
plus regardé de france est ce que ça
vous vide de quelque chose non mais je
pense que je dois avoir plusieurs
étiquettes il ya une étiquette qui
appartient aux autres c'est sur un
filtre devant l'objectif non cela leur
appartient et c'est normal c'est leur
vision de deux mois puis j'en ai
d'autres j'ai même marianne edge et les
initiales de très nature non non ça va
je serai je m'en sors assez bien au
milieu de tout ça dans le noyau dur je
m'en sors des maillots d'heure s'en sort
bien alors vous donnait pourtant
beaucoup de mal pour publier
régulièrement des livres on en a encore
la preuve aujourd'hui même si c'est une
rue publication pour entretenir de
bonnes relations avec le milieu
littéraire pour animer des émissions
littéraires consacrée au livre sur tf1
et sur lci est-ce qu'on vous donnant
tout ce mal vous n'êtes pas le sentiment
donné l'impression de flottement de vous
racheter de cette gloire médiatique un
peu facile un peu futile je pense j'ai
pas l'impression je sais que c'est pas
mon désir de départ mon désir des
départs c'est quelque chose qui est née
quand j'avais 13 14 15 ans j'ai écrit
d'ailleurs mon premier livre à cette
époque là donc je pourrais pas du tout à
la télévision c'est venu après le le
coeur de ma passion c'est le lire j'ai
essayé de défendre comme j'ai pu et
d'ailleurs dans les beaux moments de
télévision moi j'ai le souvenir du jour
vous avez reçus un 7 d'or pour justement
votre particulier une émission
culturelle et ça ça vous a fait je pense
hélas plus plaisir que des tas de succès
et la soeur audimétrique que vous tuez
vous êtes très généreux parce que quand
on voit vos émissions littéraires sur
lci sur tf1 vous invitez pas
obligatoirement des stars vous invitez
d'aider des écrivains un peu je dirais
pas le second couteau mais enfin les
écrivains que les veines probablement je
les aime je les comprends j'arrive à
comprendre ce que peut être la détresse
de quelqu'un à camille deux ans avec moi
trois ans dix ans à écrire un livre
j'essaie de ne pas trop l'abîmé peut
être pour ça d'ailleurs je suis pas
assez pugnace pas assez méchant pas
assez cynique mais je participe alors à
leur travail d'élaboration puis si
possible un peu de promotion si elle
veut les aider à être lue par deux trois
personnes décédées
des gens qu'on peut effectivement ne
font pas la une des magazines non je
sais je ne me semble pas normal ça me
paraît comment dire peut-être pour
revenir à votre première question une
façon de rendre un petit peu justice à
ce sort qui m'a donné beaucoup de
bonheur je sais que jonas donc je
redonne je redistribue du bonheur vous
avez le prix interallié c'était le
premier prix important de vous ayez eu
pour vous ça vaut ça vaut combien de
sept d'or un prix interallié m'ont tous
les sets dans tous les sens de l'intérêt
très profondément les allées les
récompenses du milieu télévisuel de
matériaux je connais un peu trop la
manière dont ça fonctionne non le milieu
littéraire bien sûr c'est normal quand
on a 12 13 ans et qu'on se dise que je
vous veux devenir un grand écrivain et
quoi on a comme l'espérance
quelque chose comme entre stendhal et
c'est chateaubriand me dire qu'on a mis
la barre assez haut qu'on se dit je vais
diplomate pour être un grand écrivain et
aigrir justement des livres géniaux
éternel impérissable dans des ambassades
de la langue y est qu'un jour il vous
aurait eu une petite récompense de cette
nature on est vachement
plus de bonheur à mon avis plus de 20
le patrick poivre d'arvor qui restera à
votre avis c'est le présentateur du 20
heures où l'écrivain tu sais pas mais
j'ai tendance à penser que les journaux
télévisés sont oubliés au moment même où
on dit au revoir parce qu'elle a un
autre qui va suivre derrière je crois
qu'on les oublie très vite des gens qui
ont marqué la télévision je dis oui oui
on met bien sûr le nom on dira toujours
quelque chose pour tout ce que vous êtes
comme là depuis quelques temps mais un
paquet de 22 ans mais bon c'est pourquoi
j'ai dit oui je ne pense les gens se
souviendront évidemment de de la
personne qui représentent elles ont été
visés pendant aussi longtemps on as soon
as longtemps parlé de gicquel qui
l'homme présentait lui pendant six ans
donc il vraisemblable on en parlera
peut-être encore un peu plus longtemps
mais au fait plus peut-être s'est pas
mêlé l'ivresse la vente un livre est un
des bibliothèques on peut les retrouver
en 2050 caché dans une langue une
vieille bibliothèque
quelqu'un peut les aimer à nouveau puis
il y aura sept auteurs étaient méconnus
ou connu pour de mauvaises raisons ce
jamais
disparaître dans l'anonymat total alors
pourquoi dans ce pays tout le monde veut
être écrivain serre que même les prisons
la république giscard mitterrand se
piquer d'écriture
le présentateur du journal télévisé même
si j'ai commencé à écrire très jeune
vous l'avez dit mais pourquoi en france
le statut d'écrivain est ce qu'il ya de
mieux finalement mais je pense qu'il ya
une vraie culture de l'écrit et essai
c'est pour ça qu'on est à mon sens plus
fort plus armé pour le 21e 22e 23e
siècle parce qu'on s'y est pris depuis
si longtemps on adore ça profondément
nador sage contre la une religion décrit
une religion du
du mot alors le verbe c'est autre chose
le verbe c'est une invention est
relativement récente bon on utilise
comme des autres on fait ce qu'on peut
mais je pense qu'il ya un respect énorme
vivier de l'objet livre paraît bien
c'est de le rester ses stats ultime
effet dans france ah oui oui bon
beaucoup l'utilisent bien sûr mouais
mais c'est pas mal au fond c'est pas si
mal mais ça que beaucoup l'utilisent il
ya des livres inintéressant bien entendu
mais s'il permet de faire lire d'autres
diffusent je suis par contre alors vous
vivez votre vie un peu comme un roman
d'ailleurs vous avez suffisamment
transformé votre nom pour qu'il devienne
le mandat héros de roman vous avez
beaucoup insisté sur votre ascendance
bretonne même cv un peu lointaine et
puis quand on regarde votre enfant c'est
votre adolescence on y voit tous les
ingrédients du roman d'apprentissage
une enfance un peu pas malheureusement
un peu terne on peut dire non j'avais
des parents qui m'aimait mégère est
restée très solide
très timide votre père jacques poivre et
et représentants dans la chaussure
toujours sur les routes qui sont allés
pour quinze jours trois semaines des
fois donc tiens peut pas abandonner
m'enfin vous retrouvez votre mère ouais
mais ma mère s'occupait bien de nous et
c'est sûr que la figue loin paraître
paternel était plus lointaines oui je
pense que je me suis assez vite réfugier
dans la compagnie des livres pour toutes
ces raisons
alors vous avez désir de gloire pas de
gloriole télévisuelle du moment de
gloire taglang avec panache vous rêviez
parlé tout à l'heure de stendhal de
châteaubriant de cyrano de napoléon la
police
j'ai bref c'est quand on habite reims
que la plaine et morne qui se passe
jamais rien qui fait il ya la brouille à
ce que c'est qu'on a le droit de la
glaise assez à ses godasses que quand on
vit dans les godasses justement puisque
mon pet dans chaussures qu'on se
promenaient dimanche pour aller voir les
autres magasins de chaussures faire des
comparatifs demain et c'est peut-être
qu'on a le désir de les prendre ses
godasses et petit speech se taillait
quoi me dépite de devenir un grand
bonhomme et je pense que beaucoup de
gens ont eu le désir oui la dart est à
paris bien sûr à nous de paris
absolument c'est un vrai roman
d'apprentissage
très jeune sentiments vous resteriez pas
là dans cette famille que vous étiez
appelé à dos un destin plus non j'étais
persuadé au contraire d'être d'être
obligé d'en laisser tout ce que je vous
disais la clé on ne bouge pas on ne
bouge pas parce qu'on est le déterminant
parce que parce que socialement on doit
être ce qu'on est parce que vos parents
vous ont fait l'essai vous laissez
entendre que d'être médecin par exemple
est ce qu'ils avaient de plus je voyais
des chiffres tout ça qui voilà donc on
pense pas tout de suite et alors
évidemment ce rebelle est allé de soi
puis à un moment donné ont réussi à
briser les jeunes a donné l'idée de
partir la force de partir les livres les
livres les lives à chaque fois je voyais
est un petit gars qui montait à paris ça
me plaît ce soit dans sa famille j'ai un
sourire tout je prends tout alors quand
tous les cas très jeune très homme
pressé là aussi on reste on reste dans
le roman à saison vous aviez votre deux
bacs vous aviez déjà écrit un livre qui
s'appelle mouyabi aida les prémices des
enfants de l'autre vous avez publié plus
tard vous avez déjà un enfant aussi à
saison donc très pressé peur de pas y
arriver tous et sans doute nous il ya
bien das aves d'un mont polonais
guillaume à ma douleur ma souffrance
j'avais trouvé ça sur des lettres de
chopin qu'il avait écrit à sa fiancée de
l'époque et ça va ça va aller bien bien
plus j'avais écrit ce livre qui est
devenu en effet plus tard les enfants
tout regret et voilà j'ai eu envie de
rêver ma vie tout ou presque tout le
temps un tout le temps je pense que
l'univers l'ivresse dans lequel j'ai été
fabriqué donc pour les raisons que je
vous ai dit
ça a fait que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
avec le réel et le même aujourd'hui
encore alors pas beaucoup d'argent pour
payer vos études est obligé de
travailler même si vous rêvez diplomate
vous êtes magasinier livreur contrôleurs
dans les trains ne fera pas n'importe
quel sera comme les wagons lits en les
dénigrant du coeur d'effacer rennes
producteur je produis j'ai rien du tout
mais les contrôleurs en effet paris
venise quand même je faisais paris
venise paris modane l'épée innsbruck
mais kloto paris venise ça m'a bien oui
tout ça j'ai découvert venise serait la
neige c'est ce week end suite venise
pendant leurs élèves savent ou norman
homme est alors vous prenez le le virus
du journalisme en 68 quand vous
distribuez au carrefour saint germain
saint michel le monde et françois quoi
vous vendiez le journal dans la rue oui
oui c'était pour me faire un peu
d'argent alors j'avais repéré un peu
l'économie de l'époque était assez
bordélique vous en souvenez sans doute y
avait donc tous et toutes ces grèves
beaucoup d'embouteillages dans les rues
puis je me dis l'aller les journaux ça
marchait vraiment très très bien
l'époque et je suis allée acheter
vraiment à l'angle du boulevard saint
germain du bois saint michel des du
démon depuis des je crois à l'époque la
35 centimes me semble utile et j'ai
acheté la part compris j'ai volé et
vendu après je suis revenu il me dira
mais c'est vraiment gentil mais vous
êtes bête vous fait pas d'argent avec ça
mais je me faisais juste pour boire à
les rues saint d'entrée des arts et là
il y avait une petite camionnette qui
vendait des jo des journaux comme ça un
peu moins cher et je les ai revendues à
mon tour puisque voilà j'en vendais 300
par jour un peu de monde est un peu de
france voir l essai la croissance visée
de vue tu veux avoir mon nom dans ce
journal non non j'ai pas pensé à demain
non non non non non j'ai toujours mon
idée oui le nom dans le journal
éventuellement metouali diversité mais
sur cette idée là dans la suite on la
connaît on va parvenir vos succès et vos
échecs vos bonheurs vos malheurs une
chose qu'on n'a jamais très bien compris
c'est comment vous gériez vos relations
avec la presse en général celle des fois
vous êtes très impudique et puis des
fois on converse très énervé devant les
assauts des paparazzi mais moi je suis
jamais public je raconte ce que je veux
dans les livres avec la licence poétique
romanesque quelques est permise je n'ai
jamais raconté ma vie ni sentimentale ni
autre dans mes livres je vais raconter
ma fille que parce qu'elle me l'a
demandé une fois ces solène est là elle
souffrait d'anorexie une première fois
puis une deuxième fois lorsque
lorsqu'elle est morte c'est à peu près
la seule chose j'en suis même sûr que
j'ai racontée deux mois je n'ai jamais
raconté qu'on a appris que vous vous a
été volée à tout tout le temps je n'ai
jamais donné mon
copyright mon accord au contraire ça m'a
souvent été extorqués dans des
conditions même parfois c'est
épouvantable c'est comme souvent ça
arrive vous réagissez comme ans devant
la devant la télé réalité justement
cirque e bonds love story disons qu'en
corse est acceptable mais quand vous
voyez par exemple que tf1 va faire
temptation island c'est à dire une île
où des couples on va essayer de détruire
des couples en envoyant des des jeunes
filles très jolie ou des garçons très
beau enfin bon ça va jusque là où voir
des émissions américaines comme le camp
et c est ce que un mot vous dit pas
moralement il faut que je m'en aille
faudrait que ce soit sur une chaîne qui
fait pas de ce genre de télévision que
j'aime pas c'est d'abord l'acception du
mot de télé réalité c'est tout sauf la
réalité c'est pour moi la réalité les
dans les jt dans le journal télévisé
ensuite son on sait que c'est très
scénarisé c'est très organisés sans et
même des merlans profondément merdes ans
est encore suivi apparemment les gens
continuent à se passionner moi ça ne me
passionne pas du tout je dis la vérité
je ne te passionne pas les barrières
morales les ai vu sauter surtout dans
des émissions type il y en a une sur
rtl9 qui police celle là je trouve sinon
vrai c'est dire si on est sur une
émission de dénonciation la haie et la
sagem font des membres mais sans que
simon so we weed sûr
mais finalement la finalité d'une chaîne
commerciale qui est d'enrichir ses
actionnaires et c'est normal et c'est
quelque part c'est pas choquant est ce
que quelqu'un comme vous avec les
préoccupations littéraires
intellectuelle que que vous avez est ce
que vous seriez pas plus à votre place
finalement sur une chaîne de service
public où l'ambition n'est pas de faire
des bénéfices mais simplement je dirais
même si ce n'est pas toujours le cas
bien entendu
d'informer les gens décident les
cultiver de leur apprendre quelque chose
est ce que vous vous devriez pas mettre
en accord la chaîne sur laquelle vous
êtes avec vos préoccupations
j'ai commencé dans le service public à 3
ans à france inter et puis disent
ensuite sur la deux
j'ai été assez vite déçu par la
tentation du pouvoir d'être s'occuper de
tous de nous conduire justement c'est ce
dont il faut parler de ne pas parler etc
sam était assez insupportable donc j'ai
assez mêlé hilali beaucoup aimé même la
liberté qu'on m'a offert de dire tout ce
que je voulais dans mon cadre à moi vous
dire que je cautionne tout ce qui est
autour de moi non je sais j'en serais
incapable et je suis franc en même temps
je ne vois plus trop bien la frontière
entre le service public et le privé moi
il me semble que la satisfaction elle ne
doit pas être celle des actionnaires est
plutôt celle des téléspectateurs me
semble-t-il alors on va parler de tf1 on
va reparler avec nos camarades tout à
l'heure il ya deux trois points discutés
en tous les cas merci je rappelle le
titre du livre qu'on en reparle dans un
instant la traversée du miroir donc de
patrick poivre d'arvor c'est chez
balland voilà et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus